sar we have been talking about storing
data say s datasets we discussed how to
import raw data files into SAS data sets
and perform different operations on them
we also discussed how to export the
process data present in SAS data sets to
standard format files an SAS report is a
representation of data present in SAS
data sets in a structured and formatted
layout which is easy to understand and
analyze
in the existing area of analytics SAS is
the most extensively used analytical
tool especially for enterprise report
processing a business report is the most
important element for analysis and the
decision support system of any business
a business report contains factual data
and summarized figures which help higher
level management to evaluate the growth
of business and make decisions SAS
provides different predefined utility
procedures to generate reports of
different types from SAS data sets let
us start this session by learning how to
create a basic report
one commonly used statements in SAS is P
ROC print we have been using this
statement throughout our session to
observe the output of our programs let
us talk about the PR OC print statement
in detail the PR OC print statement is
used to display the contents of a data
set on the output screen the syntax for
using the PR OC print statement is as
shown here SAS dataset is the dataset
whose contents are to be displayed var
is an optional keyword used after the PR
OC print statement to view only selected
variables from a dataset in the output
in absence of the var statement all the
variables present in the data set will
be displayed
remember that in case you do not use the
PR OC print statement in your program
all SAS statements will work in the same
way but no output will be shown in the
examples shown the dataset patient is
displayed in the output using the PR OC
print statement we have selected only
the variables age and weight from all
the variables present in this dataset
you can observe that SAS introduces a
column called OBS on its own in the
output you can also exclude this column
from the output by specifying the noobs
keyword after the dataset name in the PR
OC print statement in the next screen we
will discuss the label statement
if to label a variable in a detailed in
under small manner you can use the label
statement it assigns a temporary label
to a variable that is shown in the
output the syntax for using the label
statement is as shown here the label to
be assigned to a variable input is in
single quotes as an example in the
dataset patient the variable weight is
assigned a more detailed name as weight
in kgs as a label you can also observe
the effect of the newbs keyword in the
next screen we will discuss how to
include titles and footnotes in a report